[Musique]
bonsoir mes chers petits amis bonsoir
nicolas et pimprenelle ont été très
sages tous ces jours ci oh oui pas trop
et bien pour les récompenser nounours
leur a apporté un superbe bouquet de
fleurs il va leur raconter l'histoire de
ce bouquet oui j veu bon l'échelle
[Musique]
les voilà bonsoir les enfants
des charges je vous ai apporté des
fleurs
tenue
avec théo excellente idée et moi je vais
vous raconter comment est venu le
premier bouquet de fleurs là je marche
moi
il ya très très longtemps
vivre est une petite fille qui
s'appelait kazuko toumi gadret mais non
c'était une petite japonaise elle
habitait avec sa maman madame ça que
jaka une jolie petite maison en bois et
en papier elle est mignonne mais l'atout
titien c'était une petite japonaise
sa maman lui disait souvent que zookd
uni va jouer avec tes petites amies va
ramasser des coquillages au bord de la
mer mais la petite fille de voulait elle
préférait rester dans son jardin pour
s'occuper de ses amis les fleuves c'est
un jardin il sentait et elle les
appelait chacune par leur nom bonjour
iris bonjour rose
bonjour lotus
bonjour glycines mauvais les pays et
toutes les fleurs était si contente
qu'elle répondait bonjour
kazuko to me
mais voilà qu'à matin kazuko toumi ne
vint pas dans le jardin les fleurs était
triste et très inquiète que se
passait-il s'était pas réveillée elle
était partie un voyage all où elle vit
rentrer dans la maison un monsieur
habillé en noir très pressés qui porte
un une serviette de qi
satin un docteur elle était malade oui
elle était malade très malade
et quand le docteur partie de la maison
la maman de cause ou kotomi madame sac
et jaka se mit à pleurer
alors toutes les fleurs du jardin
crieur ensemble nous voulons voir kozuka
to me nous voulons voir kozuka to be
madam sac et jaka les ans 30 elle
cueilli toutes les fleurs qu'elle
pouvait porter tard tout voulait aller
voir kozuka doubi et quand la petit fils
vit entrer dans sa chambre sa maman avec
ses chers fleuve elle fut toute heureuse
et elle dit il faut vite les mettre dans
un vase plein d'eau car elles ont soif
le bouquet
venait d'honneur
[Musique]
c'était le premier bouquet oui le
premier
alors que zoug hot wheels guéri très
vite en compagnie de ses amis les
fleuves l'un des bijoux qu'elle en a
marre oui et elles vécurent ensemble
très heureuse pendant toute la durée de
sa convalescence
après après cause ou que toumi a
toujours soigné ses amis les fleurs avec
amour
allons les enfants l'histoire est finie
au lit
[Musique]
je soignerai toujours bien mais fier
elle était très jolie ton histoire
maintenant si tu nous auras contrat
encore les enfants là j'éteins la
lumière
bonne nuit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors les enfants
vous avez aimé l'histoire que vous a
raconté une source
oui eh bien allez vite vous coucher à
présent on n'y va pas trop oui en route
mon cher nounours bonne nuit les enfants
fait de pour eux vous
[Musique]
oh
m
mon
en
[Musique]